chuck i got some issues
uh oh
well i charge 175
[Laughter]
more than half of you
take my money anything that you gotta
anything that's bothering you i'm here
[Laughter]
all right what is the issue
it's the color of light
the color of light yeah so
you gotta hear me out
you got to hear me out okay okay
um i as an astrophysicist
uh
know
we have something called color
temperature
okay i am aware of that we practically
invented that concept okay i'd like
photography so that's how i know color
temperature well i'm going to get there
and you're going to find out why
i have issues okay uh-oh so
so uh here's what here's what happens if
you have an object that is of a given
temperature
uh if it's higher if it's hotter than
absolute zero it will be
radiating some electromagnetic energy
okay right so the colder it is
the longer are the wavelengths of light
it emits radio waves
the universe is pretty cold there's only
three degrees kelvin that's emitting
microwaves and the hotter it gets
the more it emits light
of higher and higher energy so let's
keep going uh eventually you can heat
this thing up
so that some of the energy that comes
out
that it emits comes out in the red part
of the spectrum
that object if you looked at it with
your eyes you'd say it's red
okay
it'll start doing that at a you know
thousand fifteen hundred degrees okay
keep increasing the temperature
it's not only giving you red light it's
also giving you light
from the rest
of the rainbow from the rest of the
optical spectrum so it'll give you not
only red but also orange yellow green
blue violet if you do that
in roughly equal amounts
the glowing object turns white
okay
because you have equal amounts of all
the colors of the rainbow so now if you
keep raising the temperature
this energy output
continues to shift and now it's emitting
more blue light than red light
if you're emitting more blue than red
through the spectrum that object will
look blue
okay okay
so i'm going from like a couple of
thousand degrees to like 6 thousand
degrees
to ten twelve fifteen twenty thousand
degrees
on my stove
i'm getting there i'm getting there i'm
getting there okay i'm getting there so
i'm saying that i'm saying hang with me
hang with me so an object goes from what
is basically invisible to you unless you
had radio wave eyeballs or microwave
eyeballs to something that's glowing
kind of
red and then it goes to amber and then
it starts glowing white and then it'll
start glowing blue
and it'll forever more glow blue but it
keeps giving you higher and higher
energy it'll give you x-rays it can even
give you gamma rays but the part of it
that comes through the spectrum
is more in the red than in the blue
so
hot things
are blue
medium temperature things
are white
cooler things that are still glowing are
red okay so if you have an electric
stove
when you first turn it on if it feels
warm but you can't see it in the dark no
okay that's giving you infrared we can't
see infrared it's got to glow so hot
that it's giving you a little bit of red
right and then you say oh it's glowing
red hot right but a red hot object is
the coolest of all hots
ah
okay damn damn that's what i'm saying
this is what i'm saying sorry red dead
okay man so when i see red hot this and
red hot that i'm saying that ain't so
bad right that ain't so bad
okay so now watch okay so that is what's
happening astrophysically that's what's
happening in the laws of physics
but now bring in the artistic
photographer
okay okay
and
in art if you're going to paint a
picture a painting you're going to
create a painting and you want the scene
to feel cool
like it's in the arctic
what is your predominant color in the
painting white white or
not just white blue blue especially blue
okay
so they say that it's cool right this is
it's a cool color and
okay and then
when they want to show something hot
like hell and devils and everything they
use the color red
all right
it's because that's how our emotions we
see ice cubes and it's
bluish and anything that got hot enough
to hurt us is glowing red hot
it's rare that you'll see something so
hot that it's glowing white or glowing
blue on earth
because that stuff gets hot enough when
it's red hot all right so our entire
life experience is shifted to the cool
end of the spectrum with us thinking
that red hot is actually hot
as a result
we have the absurd conversation between
an astrophysicist and a photographer
it's
um okay i need a cooler lamp for this
right
so what do they do
they get the 6000 degree bulb instead of
the 3000 degree bulb
this is in the days when you use
tungsten but we still think of those
temperatures even in the led world
okay
so
when they say make this scene cooler
they mean get a higher
temperature lamp
and when they say we want to make this
scene warmer
it means they want to put in a lower
temperature lamp that glows at like 3000
degrees or 2500 degrees
and i'm pissed off at this
[Laughter]
i'm just saying that's great
if you're gonna if you're gonna be
numerical about whether something is
warm or cool
do you have permission to leave the
artists behind in this conversation
scientifically illiterate troglodyte no
i'm just saying damn photographers i'm
just saying if you want to say that it's
seen as cool blue and and and warm red
fine but don't hand it a temperature
right don't give it temperatures because
you have the absurd conversation
increase the color temperature of the
lamp so that the scene it's illuminating
is cooler we'll see you guys
you have to talk to each other in
temperatures otherwise we wouldn't know
what to do so if if you're ever shooting
something and somebody says all right yo
let's let's uh give me that give me that
daylight and daylight is 5600 right it's
basically between that and 6000 and by
the way that is that is the temperature
of the sun right okay and wait wait wait
wait wait
that is the temperature of the sun and
so so when in daylight does that look
blue to you no i mean but it's bluer
than a than a
a a cooler well cooler uh lamp sure it's
more than a low temperature lamp right
but
but if you look at the 5006 that's
daylight by the way it's not yellow that
is not a yellow lamp you still have
people saying the sun is yellow so does
it no it's not the sun is freaking white
okay
right
all right
i interrupted you no you didn't i mean
that's that you basically that's what it
is but it's really like the only
reference that photographers have but
what you're saying is photographers need
to come up with a new reference um
because what they're saying is
scientifically wrong
the numbers are it's artistically
sensible but then don't put numbers on
it because these numbers mean things
right if you're going to put a 10 000
degree lamp that's a hot lamp and that's
a very blue lamp blue is hot
in the universe
that makes sense i mean now whether we
have blue stars they're 20 30 000
freaking degrees we have red stars they
call red giants they're hovering around
a thousand fifteen hundred two thousand
degrees barely glowing so i'm um
i like
what you're saying
i just like the fact that i'm i'm
changing red hot to white hot from now
on
now some people know that white hot is
hotter than red hot right it's just not
it's just not common in society blue hot
is my newest thing i'm going blue hot
all the time you know what i mean don't
you know what
all the way with a blue hot poker that's
what i want for you like
oh no the problem is it's melted but
then yeah you mean a fireplace poker
that's a problem that's right you're
right because it's oh yeah that would
melt damn yeah yeah yeah you start
melting stuff that's a that's a problem
that's why we have very little
experience with white white hot and blue
hot
um but red hot you can get almost
anything to red hot temperatures and you
don't see a lot of white hot though no
you don't know my dad was a printer and
so in printing he owned a printing
company and the coolest thing in the
plant
was how you make photo plates so the
plate is treated with a chemical that
when exposed to this
super white hot light
the image is burned onto the plate and
it's called burning a plate
right and then that image is the only
thing on the plate now that will
transfer ink
and that's how you
translate it
but they used i forget the name of these
little tubes they came together and they
and i forget it's an arc lamp that's yes
yeah carpet the light in between that's
a very high temperature arc between
there that's correct and it was the
coolest thing in the world and you
weren't allowed to look at it because it
would make you blind and right because
it's it's high in ultraviolet light it's
very high energy light right and what
they do is they have these carbon
rods basically and you you attempt to
send current through it but it has to
gap across an air gap and depending on
what your separation was and how big
your current was you could determine how
what the threshold was before you jumped
the arc right and
there it was exactly it and the whole
thing was just those two tubes and the
light in between and you had to look at
it with like the same way you look at i
forget the glass welder's goggles yeah
welders guys you got to look at it with
that same thing you look at a uh uh an
eclipse with
and it was it was the coolest thing in
the world but it was white hot
yeah yeah and and hot very clearly
hotter than anything red hot right
that's what that is so i so these are my
issues that i'm bringing to you chuck i
don't have a solution for them i'm just
highlighting them and and by the way
when i walk up to a water cooler
and and one and the the two spigots are
color-coded yes one is red and i say
okay i'm no longer in my lab i'm in the
real world and so blue is not hotter
than red they think blue is cold so
that's my i i waste i can't tell you how
much of my life i've wasted staring at
twin spigots on a water cooler figuring
out which one is the cold water
well so what we should do
is maybe the red
is hot
and then maybe
pink for like the cooler blue
one like you want to keep working on
that chuck i don't know about that keep
working oh great great no nobody wants
to drink gray water that's for sure
i'm trying to all right that's all
that's that's all i wanted to do on this
explainer that's a really cool proceed
now you got me mad at the fact that all
these things exist in life that tell us
that blue
is cooler than red because now that you
said that it's everywhere and even the
photographers know it's hotter because
they ask for a higher temperature that's
right that's that's the insidiousness of
it all all right cool anyhow i know what
we should do here's the solution
next time you see a
photographer people just punch them
did that work for you so far is that
really is that how you you did that to
your boss a few times how far that gets
you
exactly did we find you on the street
before you had this gig
i punched my boss one too many times
all right dude we got to go to quit it
there all right
thanks chuck this has been uh star talk
and explainer on the temperature and
color of light
and the fight between the
astrophysicists the artists and the
photographers
and
we the astrophysics will probably lose
but that's okay there's other fish to
fry out there not if you punch them
[Laughter]
sneak that in and low
go ahead go ahead
you get your way real fast
all right let's start talk explainer
neil degrasse tyson keep looking up
[Music]
you